hi my name is Taylor Hanul and I'm a
senior this year from Hillsdale Michigan
and I'm majoring in biochemistry it is
my pleasure today to get the chance to
introduce Mary ever stat Mary other stat
is a senior research fellow at the faith
and reason Institute a graduate of
Cornell University mrs. ever stat was a
special assistant to ambassador Jean
Kirkpatrick at the United Nations and
speechwriter to the Secretary of State
George Shultz during the Reagan
administration she has written for
numerous publications including Time The
Wall Street Journal the Washington Post
National Review first things and the
Weekly Standard she is the author of
numerous books including it's dangerous
to believe religious freedom and its
enemies how the West really lost God a
new theory of secularization and Adam
and Eve after the pill paradoxes of the
sexual revolution please join me in a
warm welcome for mrs. ever stab
thank you good afternoon and thank you
for that warm welcome it's a privilege
to be here for the first time at
Hillsdale a college I have admired and
hoped to visit for years now sincerest
thanks to the conference organizers for
inviting me and for this unique
opportunity to reflect on one of the
most critical developments not only in
recent times but in human history itself
the sexual revolution a few words about
my enduring interest in the subject like
everyone else here I have diverse
curiosities and leanings I've been
fortunate to write in many venues about
many different things but more and more
I have found that when trying to
understand the post 1960s contemporary
world
tracing matters to their roots
inevitably involves circling back to the
sexual revolution including in some ways
that we will count here today academics
vary in their definitions but here's a
straightforward uncontroversial formula
the revolution refers to the changes in
sexual behavior and mores following the
widespread adoption and approval of
reliable contraception over half a
century ago the first accelerant here is
the birth control pill widely dispersed
in the population after 1963 and the
second accelerant is the legalization of
abortion on demand in 1973 via Roe vs.
Wade
modern contraception and legalized
abortion not only changed behavior they
also changed attitudes around the world
social tolerance of non marital sex in
all its forms has risen alongside these
other changes for logical reasons that
I've talked about elsewhere including in
Adam and Eve after the pill now with the
possible exception of the Internet it's
impossible to think of any other single
phenomenon since the 1960s that has
reshaped humanity around the
world as profoundly as this revolution
some of the revolutions record is
well-known for years ago on the 50th
anniversary of the approval of the birth
control pill there was an outpouring of
commentary and reflection most of it
positive the revolution it was claimed
and acclaimed in Time magazine and other
secular venues had leveled the playing
field in the economic marketplace
between men and women as it had never
been leveled before it had also
confirmed could conferred freedom on
women such that they had never known
before
both those propositions are true as far
as they go but there's another side of
the ledger that's been mostly ignored by
a mainstream society saturated with the
revolutions pleasures with every passing
year more evidence accumulates that will
someday change that predominant happy
storyline today I'd like to discuss five
ways in which the revolution has
reconfigured reality as we know it
including reality has taken straight
from your news feeds and Twitter
headlines
so let's look in some detail at five
seeming paradoxes that point to the
revolutions power and in particular to
its awe-inspiring destructive power I'd
like to start with a little story that
captures the scale of that change in a
snapshot I grew up in a series of small
towns scattered across beautiful and
forbidding upstate New York north of the
Hudson River Valley a planet away from
New York City in an area known as the
leather stocking region where author
james fenimore cooper's set his famous
tales this was and still is rural
blue-collar country it was the kind of
place where more local boys in the 60s
went to Vietnam than went to colleges
and universities in many ways a lot
about this place is still the same as it
was when I
as a child with one massive exception
which we'll call the family thing in the
1960s most men in this area worked as
manual laborers mainly in local copper
and silver mills many women if they
married stayed home most families no
matter how chaotic were still intact
religious and non-religious alike one of
my strongest memories from those years
is an odd but significant one in 1972
just months before the legalization of
abortion a teenage girl in town became
pregnant the baby's father was a young
soldier newly returned from Vietnam the
town gossips were up in arms because as
it turned out he didn't plan to marry
her in those days that was considered
shocking although pregnant brides were
not exactly unknown and pregnant teenage
Brides for that matter men who didn't
marry their pregnant girlfriends were
objects of opprobrium eventually the
girl had the baby somewhere else where
adoption followed she came back and
finished high school to my knowledge
without stigma but the stigma that does
remain memorable was the other one the
one about her boyfriend the idea that he
should have taken responsibility which
the majority of adults in their era
certainly seemed to believe is an idea
that's now gone vanished with the
revolution now fast-forward some twenty
years in the nineteen 1990s I went back
for a visit to the same town and I saw a
former teacher she told me that in the
high school that year in a class of 200
graduating seniors one-third of the
girls were pregnant not one was married
and of course we can safely assume there
were other pregnancies besides the
visible ones because various girls were
also rumored to have gotten abortions
this too wasn't
back in 1992 that was in 1972 because
after all Roe vs. Wade had been the law
of the land for two decades so here's
the take-home from my story from one
scandalous pregnancy in a rural high
school in the 1970s too many non
scandalous pregnancies in the same
school by the 1990s
that's one snapshot showing how the
sexual revolution has changed the world
it also leads us to the first of several
paradoxes about the revolution let's
call this paradox one if the whole point
of the revolution was the availability
of cheap reliable birth control then why
did the following decades see an
unprecedented rise in both abortions and
pregnancies outside of marriage this is
a profoundly important question it's an
intellectual puzzle so puzzling that
it's come to engage attention in serious
places after all back when contraception
became commonplace many people of
goodwill defended it precisely for the
reason that they thought it would render
abortion obsolete
Margaret Sanger is one prominent if
surprising example she called abortion
barbaric and she argued that
contraception would put it out of
business
of course there's reason to wonder how
transparent she was given that Planned
Parenthood has gone on to claim her as
its patron saint but even so Sanger was
making a point that might seem to make
common sense a great many people both
before and after the 60s have believed
something similar but the empirical
record since the 1960s shows their logic
to be wrong that's exactly why research
papers and arguments have emanated from
the world of social science during the
past decades trying to explain the
puzzling fact that far from preventing
abortion and unplanned pregnancy
contraceptions effects on society
more convoluted contraception abortion
and out of wedlock births all exploded
simultaneously so consider this attempt
to solve the puzzle from over 20 years
ago by economists George Akerlof Janet
Yellen and Michael Katz writing in the
quarterly Journal of economics they
spelled out the dynamics of these
simultaneous explosions with admirable
clarity in a summary of their argument
they said before the sexual revolution
women had less freedom but men were
expected to assume responsibility for
their welfare today women are more free
to choose but men have afforded
themselves the comparable option if
she's not willing to have an abortion or
use contraception the man can reason why
should I sacrifice myself to get married
by making the birth of the child the
physical choice of the mother the
Revolution has made marriage and child
support a social choice of the Father
unquote so in other words they say
reason one why contraception led to more
pregnancy and abortion was that it
eroded the so-called shotgun wedding or
the idea that men had equal
responsibilities post contraception as
the example of the story goes to show
the reasoning became that pregnancy was
the woman's responsibility and that if
birth control failed that was not the
man's problem there is also the
secondary fact that contraception and
abortion are bound together juridically
that is to say as a matter of law as
Michael Holick professor at Catholic
University of America recently pointed
out quote as regards jurisprudence the
fruit of contraception is abortion by
1973 only eight years after Griswold the
Supreme Court in Roe versus Wade had
inferred the right from the right to
contraception a right to abortion
unquote or to put the point more kalokhe
in the matter of legal reasoning no
contraception on-demand no abortion on
demand another interesting theory about
why contraception failed to prevent
abortion comes from researchers Scot
Lloyd writing in the National Catholic
bioethics quarterly in 2015
using studies and statistics from the
abortion industry itself he argues like
others that one leads to the other he
summarizes quote the bottom line is
contraceptives do not work as advertised
and their failure is at the heart of the
demand for abortion contraception
enables sexual encounters and
relationships that would not have
happened without it in other words when
couples use contraception they agree to
sex when pregnancy would be a problem
this leads to a desire for abortion
unquote so there are several other
efforts within social science to explain
this same paradox but the larger point
stands contrary to what people back in
the 60s believed would happen abortion
and unplanned pregnancies have both
flourished despite contraception now
many people present at the creation of
the revolution couldn't possibly have
anticipated that paradoxical consequence
many people operating in good faith
hoped that humanity would master these
new technologies and that they proved to
be a social good but those of us alive
today are in possession of a wealth of
empirical evidence that's been piling up
for decades now and we can see through
perfectly secular social science that
the revolutions story took a different
and darker turn now let's look at
paradox 2 which illustrates the same
argument it goes like this the sexual
revolution was supposed to liberate
women yet simultaneously it has become
harder than before to have what most
women still say they want marriage and a
family that's not a tendentious way of
phrasing the point
women from across the political spectrum
agree that marrying and mating for life
has become more difficult than it used
to be that's one reason why biological
experiments like commercial surrogacy
and egg freezing are now being conducted
in the case of egg freezing with the
enthusiastic endorsement of the
corporate world the idea behind these
innovations is to extend the horizon of
natural fertility so that women are
freer to stay in the workplace and can
take longer to find a husband and raise
a family the idea like the idea behind
widespread contraception and abortion on
demand is to empower women and put them
in control yet here again paradoxically
many women seem to find themselves less
able than ever to get married stay
married and have a family just consider
the way this preoccupation echoes across
media and social media here are some
recent headlines from the New York Post
8 reasons why New York women can't find
a husband number 2 by the way is always
looking at your iPhone Daily Beast why
college-educated women can't find love
and there are many like-minded headlines
again from across the political spectrum
illustrating the conundrum here well as
it turns out economists have explained
the reality behind these apprehensions -
they are more an unanticipated fallout
from the revolution sociologists Mark
Regnerus has explained this very clearly
in his new book cheap sex men marriage
and monogamy which uses the tools of
economics to explain the
post-revolutionary sexual market aided
by a formidable supply of new data that
he uses to make his case so I will spare
you the data sets and regression
analyses and just go straight to the
point
Regnerus distills the essence of his
argument as follows - plenty of women it
appears that men have a fear of
commitment but men
on average are not afraid of commitment
the story is that men are in the
driver's seat in the marriage market and
are optimally positioned to navigate it
in a way that privileges their interests
and preferences unquote in other words
the same force that eroded the shotgun
wedding has gone on to empower men not
women one of the economists cited by
Regnerus is Timothy Ryker who wrote a
lengthy and like-minded economic
analysis of the Revolution in a 2010
essay for first things I recommend this
essay especially for the Economist among
young mr. Reichert argued using data
from the 1960s onward that quote the
revolution has resulted in a massive
redistribution of wealth and power from
women and children to men unquote that
is a striking formulation more
technically he points out contraception
set up what economists call a prisoner's
dilemma game in which each woman is
induced to make decisions rationally
that ultimately make her and all women
worse off unquote so let's step back
from the argument for a moment obviously
we are not speaking here of the
deliberately countercultural clubs and
communities and universities including
this one that have banded together as a
counterculture since the 60s precisely
because they want an alternative to the
dominant revolution embracing culture
but if we keep our focus on the other
side the going cultural narrative and
non-religious precincts the the kinds of
places where the revolution isn't
regarded as problematic this is what we
find in that world which is now the
cultural mainstream the fact that a lot
of men aren't settling down marrying and
having families is a constant
preoccupation it's why the phrase Peter
Pan syndrome was coined in the 1980s
it's
by the phrase failure to launch is
common shorthand today and it's why man
a lesson for those who haven't heard
that one became a noun in urban
dictionary so all of these culturally
common phenomena according to the
economists have the same origin which
has diminished incentives for men to
marry due to the flooded sexual
marketplace this outcome too is not one
that people who cheered the revolution
in this who cheered on the Revolution in
the 60s could possibly have foreseen and
it also can't be an outcome that many of
them would have wanted a third paradox
has become the dominant social social
media soap opera of the day and it goes
like this the Revolution was supposed to
empower women so why do we have the
secular sex scandals of 2017 etc and the
me2 movement in addition to the fact
that marriage for many women has become
a harder reach
there's also another paradoxical fallout
of the revolution and that's the fact
that in retrospect it licensed sexual
predation on a scale not seen outside of
conquering armies let's start with the
emblematic example of Hugh Hefner
founder of playboy who died last year
his vast empire was made of course on
pornographic photos of a great many
women he made himself an exemplar of his
own philosophy the Playboy philosophy of
sophisticated drinks and music and of
course easy sex it was a commercial idea
that caught on quickly and it seems safe
to guess that most people when playboy
started had no idea what would later
emerge from accounts within the Playboy
Mansion about the sordid truth behind
the advertising nevertheless when Hefner
died many progressives including many
stealth styled feminists glowed with
praise for this apostle of the river
lucien why because he cloaked his
predatory designs in the language of
sexual progressivism as a piece and
Forbes summarized the record Playboy
published its first article supporting
the legalization of abortion in 1965
she's well before most other venues were
signaling support that was eight years
before the roe v-- wade decision and
even before the feminist movement had
latched on to the cause it also
published the phone numbers of hotlines
that women could call and get safe
abortions unquote my point is that
Hefner's support of these causes appears
an ex trick ibly tied up with his desire
to live in a way that exploited women
and that same theme as the unwritten
common denominator that joins together
many of today's secular sex scandals the
Weinstein etc scandals revealed the same
strategic role occupied by abortion for
many other men who want to objectify
women and who disdain monogamy after all
without the backup of abortion where
would these men be they would be in
court paying child support now in this
case too more and more thinkers outside
the religious sphere have come to
conclude the same thing the revolution
did not deliver on its promises to women
instead it further enabled men
especially men without the best of
intentions consider this quotation from
non-religious social scientist Francis
Fukuyama author of the end of history
this comes from his 1999 book the great
disruption which is about the 60s he
said quote one of the greatest frauds
perpetrated during the great disruption
was the notion that the sexual
revolution was gender neutral benefiting
women and men equally in fact the
revolution served the interests of men
and in the end put sharp limits on the
game
that women might otherwise have expected
from their liberation from traditional
roles unquote that's almost 20 years ago
and with that observation mr. Fujiyama
joins a long and growing list of
non-religious thinkers who can now see
more clearly in retrospect what some
religious leaders have been saying all
along again
the revolution effectively democratized
sexual predation no longer did one have
to be a king or a master of the universe
to sexually abuse or harass women in
unrelenting serial fashion all one
needed was a world in which many women
would be assumed to use contraception
and in which many would also be further
deprived of male protectors in other
words all one needed was the world
delivered by the revolution a fourth
paradox that has barely been studied at
all at least not systematically needs to
be and that is the effect of the
revolution on Christianity itself to
look back over the decades is to
understand that the revolution is
simultaneously polarizing the church's
within and creating tighter ties among
different denominations than ever before
for a long time after the 60s
commentators have argued about what the
60s meant for the churches some welcomed
the innovations of Vatican 2 for example
and the radical theological
transformations of mainline
Protestantism others deplored these
changes but wherever they have stood
observers of Christianity today have
come to find one central fact
unavoidable the revolution is the single
most divisive issue now afflicting the
faith itself and this is recognised by
Protestants and Catholics on both sides
of the divide in 2004 for example a book
called a church at war by ste
and bates about the anglican communion
summarized the argument on its back
cover will the politics of sex tear
Anglicans and Episcopalians apart i
think we know the answer to that one a
few years later writing of the same
subject in a book called mortal Follies
Episcopalians and the crisis of mainline
Christianity author William Murchison
concluded his argument with this
observation for Episcopalians as for
large numbers of other Christians the
Paramount issues today are sex and
sexual expression neither viewed by the
culture as a means to an end but as the
end unquote in his 2015 book onward
Russell Moore reflected on the tensions
between evangelical progressives and
traditionalists like this quote when it
comes to religion in America at the
moment progress always boils down to sex
unquote and there are many more quotes
that I could give you making the point
that this truth is now widely recognized
so once more as in our other examples it
seemed safe to say that the divisive
nests out there today in the churches
wasn't anything that most Christians of
the 1960's wanted to embrace the point
is that those voices within the church's
decades ago who just wanted Christianity
to loosen up didn't know what they were
starting which is today's figurative
civil war across denominations within
the faith itself a fifth and four now
final paradox the revolution didn't stop
at sects what many people thought would
be a private transformation of relations
between individuals has gone on to
radically reconfigure not only family
life but life period perhaps the least
understood of the revolutions effects
are these what might be called the macro
cosmic consequences the way in which it
continues to affect not only individuals
but society and politics both some of
these changes are
demographic across much of the world
families are smaller and more splintered
from within than ever before in history
some effects are political smaller and
more fractured families have put
unprecedented pressure on the welfare
states of the Western world by reducing
the tax bases required to sustain them
there are also social effects and some
of these are only beginning to be mapped
like the sharp rise in people living
alone or in reporting or in people who
report greatly reduced human contact or
other measures that make up the
burgeoning field of what's called
loneliness studies and then there's the
spiritual fallout which also couldn't
have been foreseen in the 60s I have
argued elsewhere that the revolution has
given rise to a new secularist quasi
religious faith the most potent such
body of beliefs
since Marxism Leninism according to this
new faith pleasure is the highest good
and there is no clear moral standard
beyond consent for anything that adults
wish to do with one another
whether they are conscious of it or not
many people in what is now the
mainstream culture of our world treat
the sexual revolution as religious
bedrock off-limits for revision no
matter what consequences it has all of
these are just some examples of the new
world that needs mapping out there and
that will come to absorb intellectual
attention for what we should hope is a
long time to come and there's grounds
for optimism it's taken over 50 years
after all for opinion including
non-religious opinion to realign about
just some of the revolutions negative
legacy
it may take 50 more or a hundred for a
full and honest empirical and
intellectual accounting revisionist
thinking about the revolutions effect in
the world however has only just begun
in closing one parting thought
the great Russian writer Leo Tolstoy was
once sent by a journal to report about
what happened in a local slaughterhouse
what he saw there moved him deeply his
subsequent description included an
immortal line that I think applies
widely including to us here today after
relaying the facts of the matter Tolstoy
observed with devastating simplicity we
cannot pretend we don't know these
things and that I think is exactly where
humanity is in 2018 with respect to the
sexual revolution we can no longer
pretend we don't know these things
back in the 1960s people could plead
ignorance including in good faith about
the fallout to come many had no idea how
many millions of children would
subsequently grow up without fathers or
how many more millions would be aborted
or just how much people from fractured
homes might suffer in diverse ways
including turning to drugs and other
self-destructive behaviors many people
back then hoped that the revolution
would not incur collateral damage and in
fairness who could have foreseen the
library of social science that would be
built over the next 50 years documenting
just some of the human damage out there
some people 50 years ago even hoped that
the new freedoms and technological
controls would have a stabilizing effect
on marriage itself as everyone knows the
1968 papal encyclical Humanae Vitae
which also reaches its fiftieth
anniversary this year went on to become
widely despised across the decades
precisely for arguing otherwise for
saying that the revolution would hurt
romance and family and end up licensing
predatory men and malignant governments
in many places it's still reviled for
those reasons a great many people
including within the Catholic Church
have ferociously resisted human evita's
rejection of the revolution
including in some pretty high places but
again in 2018
can we still in good faith pretend we
don't know these things in 1953 when the
first issue of Playboy arrived on
newsstands many people might have wanted
to believe its market hype about
enhancing the sophistication and
urbanity and grooming of American men
but by 2018 we can't pretend that this
mainstreaming of Pinnock pornography has
been anything but a disaster for romance
and a prime mover of today's divorces
and other breakups
similarly in 1973 even supporters of roe
v wade could not have imagined the
evidence to come some 58 million never
born micro humans in the United States
gendercide or the Selective killing of
girls for being girls in various
countries around the world also
numbering in the millions Norwood
supporters back then have imagined the
technological leap that would unveil the
truth about abortion once and for all
the sonogram machine can today's
advocates for Roe claim the same
unknowing that they could too faced
facts squarely and to use them to tell a
truthful story is not to deliver a
jeremiad it is to empower going back to
the example of Tolstoy his observation
about not pretending wasn't just some
pretty literary turn it it's a banner to
carry through life to reject living
under the falsehoods told by others
about the revolution even if they are
now the dominant narrative of the age is
to embrace the freedom to write a new
narrative and a truer one only one step
is needed toward revising the
revolutions legacy in the direction of
truth ceasing to pretend that we don't
know the record when every single year
reveals it more and more thank you
[Music]
thank you mrs. ever stet
has graciously agreed assigned copies of
her book Adam and Eve after the pill
paradoxes of the sexual revolution
immediately following the lecture
outside of Phillips auditorium we now
have time for a few questions please
raise your hand and wait for a
microphone to be brought to you Supper's
not thank you so much for coming out and
speaking to us today so in 2015 the
United States Supreme Court heard the
case of Berger fell versus Hodges in
which Justice Samuel Alito asked then
Solicitor General Donald Verrilli what
is going to be the impact of this
decision on private colleges and
universities that refused to recognize
same-sex marriage in the same sense that
for instance Bob Jones refused to
recognize interracial marriages and
verelli respond this is going to be an
issue so my question to you is do you
agree with verelli is this going to be
an issue for colleges moving forward if
so and if not if you could talk to us a
little bit about what the role of law is
going to be here moving forward after
that decision
thank you so much first let me say I'm
not a lawyer so I'm not qualified to
speak to the law but I'm glad you
brought up Justice Alito I think in his
opinions he has seen most clearly that
what we're talking about here when we
talk about secularism and religion is
actually two rival faiths and he saw
that very clearly and he saw that if the
state enshrined one which it has for
some intents and purposes the other
would suffer which it is I think we're
all pretty aware of that calling
attention to this struggle as a struggle
between religious faiths I think is more
true to the facts than saying that it's
about secularism versus religious belief
people are wired to believe something
the question is always what so I think
just for starters we have to like keep
breaking the ground of making the other
side understand that what they're
talking about is their own set of
religious beliefs and that the state has
to be even-handed between
those things yes ma'am you mentioned the
the effect of the revolution on
Christianity what about on Muslim aspect
that's a great question and it's not
something that I feel qualified to talk
about but about Christianity I think
it's very interesting that in the case
of Protestantism as well as Catholicism
what's ended up happening is a Christian
explosion across Africa and in this
explosion more and more because of the
civil war within the Western churches
people are looking to leadership from a
more traditional
the issues that consume us these social
so-called social issues are not the
issues that consume African Christians
for the most part and I think one of the
reasons for optimism is that we can
expect leadership from that quarter and
it will be unafraid leadership that
won't be pulled as pulled into the
secularist mainstream that we have thank
you for speaking miss Deborah Scott
you've spoken a great deal about the
negative effects of the sexual
revolution here in the United States and
touch briefly on international
demographics in the post-revolution
world could you further elaborate on the
extent to which in your view American
culture has exported these negative
effects to foreign countries and give us
any ideas you have that could help us
begin reversing that process
well that's easy I think just as we look
back on the 60s and say wow that looks
weird now you know this looks weird this
looks weird this looks weird I think in
50 years one of the things that's going
to look really weird in the rearview
mirror is that you have people like
Melinda Gates and the Gates Foundation
proselytizing for contraception all over
places with poorer darker people this is
a very peculiar thing and it sends a
really I think arrogant message which
used to be known as the ugly American
you know the American who goes around
the world and stomps around trying to
impose his views on everybody else this
is a particularly I think noxious area
where the view of America that people
have in places like India Africa others
one could name is partly the view of
white people coming in and saying the
solution to our problems is there should
be fewer of you I don't mean this is
what the people who do this kind of
proselytizing have in mind I don't
certainly don't think they're conscious
of it but that is what it looks like
very often on the receiving end and I
think just having a little more humility
about our nongovernmental organizations
and the imaged negative image that they
send of the United States I think that
would be a good thing for starters and
just raising consciousness about it
seems to be the way to go thank you so
much for your talk you mentioned that
the Catholic Church is headed up a lot
of the attack against the the sexual
revolution the pushback with Humana
vitae and Pope John the Paul Pope John
Paul the second theology of the body and
there's been a lot of division among
other denominations about what to do
about this what do you think the role of
the evangelical church should be and
what should they do to try to get behind
the effort to push back against the
sexual revolution
like I have enough trouble trying to
tell the Catholic Church what to do you
know it's it's really interesting I
think within both traditions there's a
certain diehard contingent that comes
straight out of the 60s that is not
reproducing itself literally or
figuratively that is to say when you
look at who leads the charge on backing
away from traditional teaching these
days it's not the younger people I mean
the younger people are coming into the
churches Protestant and Catholic alike
because they're looking for orthodoxy
they're looking for something real you
know I mean that is the signal thing
about the Millennials that everybody
agrees on that they're looking for
something authentic so those people are
on the traditionalist side of the
equation and over time I think it's
going to make some of this fewer just go
away one book I would mention in this
regard is there's a demographer named
Eric Kaufmann who wrote a book some of
you may have heard of it's called shell
the religious and here at the earth and
he makes the point he's perfectly
secular but he shows that over time you
can expect that religion will not only
not go away but that the heterodox
elements of it will eventually peel off
and the reason is that the more
religious people are the more they have
families of size he calls this the iron
rule of demography and over time the
younger more faithful more Orthodox
elements you know sort of once they put
granny on the iceberg but you know they
tend to have they tend to become more
and more of the flavor of the church so
this summer in New York City I met a lot
of young Christian women who were single
and looking for love and I'm wondering
are there ways to I mean I mean
there and my favorite I mean they were
like they went to church and like I just
met up with them in groups and they said
you know we have these problems that
there are just people and there's not a
lot of men like who are in seem to be
interested in awesome so I'm wondering
are there ways to level the playing
field I guess somehow in dating between
men and women oh is that not a problem
do you think of the cycle I mean I guess
I'm interested in what you have to say
well remember the New York Post says
stop looking at your iPhone
the first Harder's but in a way no
because we're up against biology I mean
that's the whole point of freezing eggs
right is that men most men are fertile
until forever and and women are not
without a great deal of artificial
interference so that's what egg freezing
is for if that's where we have to go to
level the playing field and I mean my
guess would be we need to look at the
playing field differently or build a new
one which is what I see in these you
know encounter cultural communities all
the time who are not playing by these
rules who are not on tinder who are not
you know shopping for people that way
and I think there is a lot to be said
that's optimistic like that because the
1960s not only gave rise to the
counterculture of its time it also has
given rise to a very opposite
counterculture that we see in places
like this that we see in a lot of campus
groups including on secular campuses of
and all of that is grounds for hope so
again no jeremiad
so I mean are there ways that the church
can help with that because I think these
were young Christian women and they just
like weren't having any I like there was
just no men who are stepping up and do
you think that's pervaded the church but
there's like no no dating happening and
I don't know I don't think he was just
for like one church group that I went to
it was several church groups that I went
to over New York and it just seemed to
be kind of a common problem so I'm
wondering like how can the the church
help with that or like what ya know I
mean clearly some of what's going on
here is that people are using tinder and
other kinds of you know things on their
phone to meet people because the
churches are not doing what historically
they did and that's not to dump on the
churches but I mean in Washington DC
where I'm from I can think of a number
of venues for young adults that are
specifically you know designed for this
that is not in a creepy way of like you
know on mass matchmaking but just to
bring people together who have shared
ideas and who don't want to be meeting
in bars and on tinder so yeah I'm sure
there's a lot more that churches could
all do in this regard hi my question is
with today's media presence that kind of
jumps at the slightest word against this
empirical evidence as to kind of the
true reasons for the decline in our
culture what in what ways can we gently
educate the populace as to the actual
empirical evidence behind these kind of
down downward spirals maybe in a less
controversial way say than like a ben
shapiro figure oh yeah i think there's
plenty of it I mean what I try to do in
part is look at evidence that's not
coming from religious precincts because
I think that's very powerful evidence
I'll give you an example some of you
those of you who listen to Eminem
probably know that he has a new song
suck my ed sheeran called the river and
it's very moving
upsetting song came out last month it is
man expressing his fury and his remorse
over an abortion that is perfectly
secular evidence that the idea that
arose from the 1960s that's enshrined
and roe v wade you know the blob of
tissues idea is just untenable I mean if
someone like raps biggest superstar can
see that and put that out there that's
proof that the ground has really shifted
I think we should look for openings like
that I think we should make you know
common cause with feminists when the
occasion suits I'll give you an example
there's I think one fully one member of
the board of now who is against
commercial surrogacy because she thinks
it exploits women so you know when the
church were the one that churches
resonate with natural law and come up
with these rules for Humanity we have to
have faith that that's not arbitrary
that's like resonating with something
about human nature that other people can
see including people who are not
churched and I think the final proof of
this is the fact that on the social
issues support for abortion has been
dropping among younger people ever since
say the invention of the sonogram so
there we have another case where you
know people just don't want to go there
just because of the evidence that
they've seen and I think you know we
should work with all of that I think
there's a big coalition out there
waiting to happen
on abortion on the life issues that
might swing the pendulum the other way
and on some other stuff
thank you mrs. Evers dad for coming to
speak here at Hillsdale I do one
cultural trend I noticed that resulted
from the sexual revolution is the
loosening a standard for modesty and
dress especially for women women and so
you said want this the step that we need
to take is to not is to acknowledge that
the sort of truth behind what has
resulted from the sexual revolution so
would you think that churches
acknowledging acknowledging the problem
of set of dress and modesty do you think
that could be a good step in trying to
undo the damage of the psycho revolution
yeah I think that's a great point I mean
that is something that gets soft peddled
and it's also something that everybody
who's the parent of a daughter is aware
of and again I mean I think there could
be quite a lot to work with there yeah
but part of what we're up against here
is that a lot of women have been told
have imbibed the lie that you know
they're kind of interchangeable units
with men they're not and so to establish
standards for modesty it has to be
explained the ways in which the sexes
differ but yes I'm sure there's a lot of
education that could be done that way
thank you
great point you've spoken a lot about
how this issue affects females and
certainly it's a very female centric
issue but my question is in the secular
world there's very much the claim that
men should not speak about topics such
of this and they have no business kind
of interfering in abortion and in birth
control pills so my question is to what
degree is that the responsibility of one
or both sexes to reverse this trend and
how can men kind of get their foot in on
the secular field in addressing these
issues when they're largely told they
shouldn't speak about them well I mean a
little spine I I don't mean that
demeaning Lee I mean to say like we have
to be careful ourselves that we don't
absorb lies of the kind that I was
describing in the speech and one of
those lies is the idea that you're not
privileged to speak about X Y or Z
unless you line up a B or C on the
identity calculus I mean if anything I
think trying to appeal to other people's
reason and giving them the dignity of
being considered full conversational
partners is something that's a very good
example to the other side because the
other side doesn't usually
do it so I would say if there are men
hanging back from this discussion
because they feel like they don't have
standing to have an opinion then they've
bought into a kind of false
consciousness that they need to leave
behind somewhere you've spoken some
about how damaging apps such as tender
can be to the modern dating culture and
I'm just curious like do you think that
religious dating apps such as Christian
mingle and J swipe are in ways similarly
exploitive and damaging to the formation
and foundation of relationships like is
the Internet culture of instant
gratification in dating still damaging
even when it's not secular I think
getting in the habit of shopping for
human beings the way you would shop on
Amazon has got to take its toll that's
not to say there aren't worse ways of
doing it or better ways of doing it but
fundamentally and I would appeal here to
Mark Regnerus his book which I urge
anybody interested in this stuff to read
cheap sex which just came out he has a
sensational title but the numbers are
anything but sensational and he is
particularly concerned with tinder and
related apps he actually makes the
argument that the three big
technological leaps have been the birth
control pill the invention of really
high quality internet pornography and
third he puts this on the same level
devices that are you know absent that
allow you to shop for people and one
thing he's able to show is that the more
of these are used the less likely it is
that any one of them sticks because
there's always the thought well if this
one doesn't work out tomorrow morning I
can just you know go back to that so I
was here all day yesterday went home and
I rose this morning to discover that the
Senate yesterday failed to pass
legislation which would have prohibited
abortions after
weeks very disappointing to read that
apparently there were actually two
Republican senators who voted to not go
along with the legislation and of course
I believe all the Democrats did it had
already been passed in the Congress side
on the house side and failed in the
Senate so my question for you is do you
think that in some ways this matter of
abortion has really become more of a dog
whistle issue for a lot of Republicans
who are in fact they actually don't want
it to be changed because they know they
can continue to blow this whistle and to
bring conservatives to vote for them but
when the rubber meets the road they're
actually unwilling to do what they do
the right thing in this matter
I was at the March for Life a couple of
weekends ago and President Trump said a
few things that indicated that if
legislation were passed that he would
actually sign it and it seems we've got
a Republican House we have a Republican
Senate we have a Republican president if
if this is ever going to happen it seems
like now is the time for it to happen
otherwise really the Republicans are
just cowards on this matter and they're
using it to manipulate conservatives do
you would you agree with that what is
your opinion on that I can't speak to
the state of their souls I don't know
how many people on the Republican side
are cynics are opportunists about this
but I would point to a couple of reasons
for optimism one is the fact that the
decline in support for abortion among
younger voters especially is something
that is going to have to be reckoned
with it may not be this year it may not
be 10 years from now but it shows no
sign of declining and it's something
that politicians will have to take into
account as a subsidiary point it was
noted after the election that it was
said by some Democrats and progressives
maybe we've been too absolutist about
abortion
maybe that's where
you know we could do a little
compromising and get a pro-life voice
back on our party again now so far not
much has come of that but I think the
fact that that thought emanated upwards
and from various people suggests that
eventually the Democratic Party is going
to have to stop is going to have to
relinquish its current absolutism on
this and the other reason for optimism
is that I was also at that March for
Life and it's unmistakable the the face
of that movement is a young face and the
other side has nothing to match it again
because neither literally or nor morally
do they reproduce themselves in this way
there are plenty of young women
including young celebrities who they put
up but they don't have anything like
that show of force that's on them all
and sooner or later the fact that like
whatever you think about abortion you
have to acknowledge that we've got the
most extreme such regimen in the world
almost that too is going to have to be
reckoned with and I think by both
parties so disappointing though that
outcome that particular outcome was I
think keep trying is probably the best
thing to say about it
we have time for one more question well
one of my questions is the impact on
children
first of all you you talked about things
that we can see at one point parents
prided themselves and the number of
children they could have today we seem
to think small families are the norm and
also it's the impact on the fatherless
homes you know the number of children
that are living in split homes these are
things that anyone can see in our
society you know what Western
civilization is not repeat reproducing
itself there is but there are two kinds
of evidence here are the evidence of one
census right in word what one
see including in one's own surroundings
and then there's also what I only
referred to glancingly just because it's
too large to get into the entire library
of social science establishing all the
various connections between the
fractured family and bad outcomes for
kids bad outcomes defined as things that
I think most of us are familiar with
lower educational achievement higher
criminality etc and of course it upsets
people to hear about this because
something like half of almost half of
all kids in America are now going to
grow up without their biological father
in the home so that's a lot of you know
collateral damage but we need to
recognize it as collateral damage and
again you know as with other elements of
this general argument I would look for
friends in unexpected places
I've had occasion to write elsewhere
about popular music you know as jarring
as it sounds two people who grew up with
the Beach Boys there's a lot to work
with and the music out there because a
lot of it is reflecting all of these
themes of you know what it's like to
come from a tumultuous home what it's
like not to know your father etc and
this is especially dominant in rap music
interestingly enough so I would just try
to build bridges wherever we can to the
understanding that the way many people
are living now is unnatural not their
fault but unnatural nonetheless and that
there's like a better place where we can
get this country
[Applause]